[inaudible] the only regret that I have is that we couldn't do more because
guess what?
After America did pull out isis took Ramadi,
and when they got in Ramadi and we had friends that were there,
Isis went and found the families that had worked with coalition forces
prevalently and they murdered about 500 families.
So that sickens my heart that that's horrible.
So when you hear that politically,
it sort of gets back to,
we were talking about earlier that,
you know,
when they say,
all right,
well we're going to get out this day like,
oh,
it's gotta be over.
We've got in this thing,
we got to get out this day.
And you know that that's counter to what you've learned sort of on the ground.
That's just gotta be the worst thing you could hear.
Yeah.
One of the words,
even if you don't want a conflict to continue,
first of all,
there's no one that wants conflict less than the people that have to go and
fight it.
Right.
When we sign up for a war,
it's my friends and not just my friends,
but it's the military that's going to go out and die.
When,
when we sign up,
oh,
there's a conflict we need to take care of.
So yes,
uh,
we don't want to go to war.
If you go to war,
you go to war to win.
In the situation that happened in Iraq,
we pulled out completely.
There was not,
there was no one that had fought in Iraq that thought,
Oh,
good call.
That's a great call there.
There was embers of the inserts.
The insurgency had been,
had been all but crushed,
but it had not been completely extinguished.
And there were embers of insurgents that were there.
And as soon as we pulled out,
they started growing.
And that's what turned into Isis.
Yeah.
So that's,
that's around 2008 ish,
right?
Something like that.
Yeah.
So then what,
what is sort of a more sensible way of leaving something?
So you could,
you do a certain amount of cleanup,
let's say,
and you freeze some of these cities and,
and good things have happened,
but you don't want to be there forever.
How do you manage that?
That end with the stresses of just the political machinations and all that
stuff?
Yeah,
I mean that's,
that's something that you have to look at every situation that you're in and you
have to say,
okay,
well what can we do here?
How,
how much can we draw down our troops?
And it's not,
it's not a certain amount of time.
It's not a certain amount of troops.
You,
you have to look at each situation and do an assessment and figure out the best
way to move forward and guess what you won't,
you won't be perfect.
And,
and that's why an absolute thing like,
hey,
we're just gonna,
we're not going to do this anymore,
is a risky move.
So what do you think's go?
So like when Obama did that,
what do you think his military leaders who,
I'm sure you probably respect some of them or maybe even know some of them.
What do you think they were telling him that because it's so counter to what
you're laying out here.
I'm sure they told them,
this is not a good idea.
This is not a good idea.
There's,
like I said,
there's no one that had spent time on the ground in Iraq that said,
Oh,
you know what?
We're good.
Let's leave.
Because it was still a very,
a very fragile situation.
Yeah.
And uh,
it looked good.
It looked good on paper,
but you have to give the,
the civilian populace enough time to really kind of figure out how to live this
way because it's a new way to live.
You're oppressed under Saddam,
then you're oppressed under some insurgency.
And to have that be lifted and then say,
okay,
we look around,
it's gonna take some time to figure out how we're going to do this.
And we needed to provide them with enough security and stabilization that they
could.
It's not like we were working hard.
The last few Lafe uh,
who wrote the book books with me,
he deployed in 2010 I want to say they had,
so what?
While I was in Ramadi,
there was a guy wounded or killed almost every day for the six months in,
we were,
there was a guy wounded or killed almost every day and robotic,
sometimes two,
sometimes five,
sometimes seven,
sometimes one when life went back to Al Anbar province.
So LMR province that the province that Ramadi is the capital of.
In his six month deployment,
there was one fatality for all of coalition forces money who is from a vehicle
rollover.
Wow.
So it was,
it wasn't like we were over there gutting it out anymore with the insurgence.
The insurgence had been really,
really suppressed and we just needed to give the locals enough time to kind of
put things together and start to move forward and become stable,
politically stable,
economically stable.
And that is what we should have done.
Do you think it's our moral responsibility to do actions like this?
If we,
if we can help people that are living in these horrible situations that morally
and at we,
I mean we,
the United States have to do it.
I think that we have to weigh the morality of taking care of other people and
taking care of our own people.
Right?
So when you,
and this is a very difficult decision to make and some that I've talked about on
my podcast was the genocide in Rwanda.
So the genocide in Rwanda happened and there was 800,000 Tutsis that were killed
by Hutus in a hundred days.
So this is more efficient than Hitler was able to pull it off.
And by the way,
most of the killing was done,
98% of the killing was done with machetes.
So this was just crazy when that was happening,
I was sitting off the coast with a Inicio platoon on a ship with a bunch of
marines,
a bunch of navy power,
and we could have gone in there and done something.
And we did.
And I would say that the primary reason that we didn't is because a year
earlier,
Black Hawk down had happened.
And we lost a bunch of service members in Somalia.
And so I was like,
hmm,
you know what?
We don't really want to get involved in that again.
And so that's what we have to weigh is we have to wait,
what are we willing to lose in order to save someone else?
And then what do we benefit from saving those people?
And is that benefit worth the,
the expense in money and lives that we invest into it.
And sure,
some of that benefit is feeling like we can look ourselves in the mirror as a
country.
That's part of the benefit.
Part of the benefit might.
Sure there's economic benefits.
Sure there's political benefit.
But part of the benefit is can we look in the mirror and say,
you know what,
we almost a million people were butchered in this country and we didn't do
anything about it.
That's something that we have to contend with.
And that's why these decisions are hard to make.
And,
and when you do make these commitments as a country,
then you need to commit and not go halfhearted into these efforts.
If you're gonna,
if you're gonna risk American lives,
you better be doing it for a reason.
That is that merits putting our,
our men and women at risk.
What do you make of the catch 22 that America's in with this dilemma all the
time where it's like,
if we don't do anything,
no one does it,
but then every time we do do something,
there's always the unintended consequences and how long do we have to be there
and everything else.
It's a really,
it's a,
it's a strange bargain that America's sort of put in or put itself in.
Well,
yeah.
Then this is,
we started off this conversation talking about leadership and why leadership is
so hard.
Leadership is hard because decisions,
it's not two plus two equals four.
It's,
it's,
it's not that at all.
There's this insane amount of calculus and and secondary and tertiary things
that happen after you make a move that you think is good.
This is what makes it so hard and that's why,
you know,
for America as the leader of the free world,
guess what?
Being in that leadership position,
it's a hard position to be in.
And,
and guess what?
Just like a leader,
just like when I was a leader,
when I was a leader of a scope to and when I was leader of a seal.
Tasking,
did I do everything perfect?
Absolutely not.
I made mistakes.
I made mistakes,
I made mistakes where people died.
And that is the burden of leadership that you bear.
And so as a nation,
we're in the same situation.
The things that we do,
we are not going to do things perfectly.
We have to do them with the best intent,
which I believe we do.
But things aren't going to go perfectly.
And guess what?
Some people are going to be mad when you make those mistakes.
Some people are going to be mad.
Even when you do things right,
they're going to look at you and say,
Oh,
you shouldn't have done that.
That was the wrong thing to do.
Okay,
here's what we weighed out.
And you've gotta be willing to take those criticisms.
Leadership leadership has a very hard thing.
So what do you make of the guy in the White House now related to leadership?
Because even if we were just to look at her rack,
so it's like,
all right,
George W.
Bush got us into Iraq.
You can argue whether that was good or bad or whatever.
Obama got us out and as you just laid out,
maybe the way we got out was probably not the right way to do it.
It doesn't seem that from at least what I could tell that Trump is looking to
get us into extra awards or anything like that.
Well,
it certainly doesn't seem like he's looking to get us into any extra words.
I would agree with that.
And again,
there's,
I don't believe that,
hey,
we're going to be an isolationist nation and we're not gonna play on the world
stage.
I don't think that's the best thing.
The other end of the spectrum is,
hey,
we're going to go fight and police up,
but world,
that's not the right thing either.
The right thing is to look at each situation as it unfolds in the world and
make,
try and make the best decisions you can as a leader at that time.
And,
and again,
these are not easy decisions to make.
These are,
these are decisions that you make them and they still unfold the day after you
make a decision.
The minute after you make a decisions,
things unfold that you didn't expect,
that you didn't anticipate,
and yet you made a decision.
So now you've gotta make another decision.
And,
and it's,
it's a challenge.
What do you make of him just as a leader,
if we were looking at the gray the way you would grade a leader,
how would you look at Trump from a leadership perspective?
Yeah,
I think Trump is an interesting characteristic of some really broad extremes,
right?
So he does things that I say,
Oh,
good move.
And then literally 20 minutes later,
20 minutes later,
I'll be thinking to myself,
what,
how can you even think that this is,
uh,
a decent thing to do?
Right?
And,
and by that I mean,
you know,
jumping out on Twitter and criticizing some kind of,
pursue some,
some individual humans,
celebrity or celebrity.
Yeah.
Hey,
what are you doing?
Why,
why are you doing that?
Uh,
you know,
so I think the guy who was it that just the,
the testimony that just took place and Michael Color.
Yeah.
So Michael Coleman gets up and says that Trump is a bad character
and I'm like,
okay,
you know,
I mean this is,
this to me is not a surprise.
I mean,
I don't think this is a big surprise.
Anyone.
This is not,
this is a guy that he's not the guy that you want your daughter to marry.
At least.
At least I don't want my daughters to marry someone like that.
Okay.
So what's his character like?
Not the one that we want to model ourselves after.
Do we want,
do we expect,
do we want a leader to be someone that we can look up to and model ourselves
after?
Absolutely.
We want to look at us,
look at our leader and say,
wow,
I really respect that person and I want to follow them and I'm going to emulate
their,
their actions and their behavior.
That's,
that's absolutely,
that's what a leader is.
Yeah.
So does Trump fall short on that?
Oh yes he does.
Yes he does.
So it's a,
it's a strange world that we live in,
that that guy versus Hillary Clinton who he ran against.
Neither one of those people are people that,
that you look at and say seems like,
seems like a character I want to emulate.
That's what I'm looking towards.
I want to be that person.
I want to,
I want to move in that direction.
You know,
from the 300 plus million people in America,
those are the two candidates that we put forward.
One is wrong with us.
Yeah.
That's a problem.
Well,
what is wrong with this?
What do you think the answer to that is?
Is that just the way the political system set up or is that the media or is that
us?
Is it all due to the political system?
For sure.
I think it has to do with the,
the way that,
the way that media is and the waste celebrity is that the name is able to carry
itself.
The character that Burton a self branding that goes out,
I think drives so much of this that we're not really,
we're not really assessing what type of leader this person is going to be.
We're assessing how popular they are.
So for a guy that talks about discipline a lot,
when you see Trump tweeting,
is that what's going on in your head?
You're like,
man,
this is just a discipline thing.
Like you get some of these things right?
And if you could just discipline yourself in another way.
Yeah,
I would say that.
I thought when,
when Trump won the election,
and I was just as surprised as anyone when Trump won the election,
I thought,
okay,
well you know what,
at least now we're going to get to see him step up and act presidential,
all that.
What did it take 15 minutes before he looked at it and said,
okay guys,
okay,
it's gonna take him a little bit longer than I thought.
But,
but it hasn't changed and it was the same thing.
You'd see Hillary Clinton do the same types of things where you do doing
behavior that you'd say to yourself,
why are you doing that?
W W w.
W.
W you don't do that.
You don't do those kinds of things.
You don't behave that way and so
I think you just have to,
you know,
we have to kind of go through,
I hope that this is a situation where this is a a point,
a pivot point for the country where we'll start looking around and saying,
okay,
we don't really want to do that.
We want to look for the right person that's going to do this job correctly.
That's going to represent the country well and are you worried that we don't get
out of this?
Whatever this thing is that everyone can sort of feel and no one knows exactly
what what it is.
Just this,
this endless bickering and how it seems like social media is making us all hate
each other and then we don't,
that we don't have real,
at least at the political level leaders to look up to.
If you're looking for self discipline and morality and whatever else,
you know,
when people,
I had people right when Trump got elected,
you know,
people would just fly off the handle with me.
Right?
And,
and I don't really talk about politics very often.
And the reason I don't talk about politics very often is because,
well,
because from a leadership perspective,
if I'm trying to get you to do something,
the worst way to lead is for me to bark at you and tell you what to do.
That's not good leadership.
So I don't do that with people that I communicate with.
I don't say,
Hey,
he's,
he's horrible and she's great,
or she's horrible.
And he's got,
oh,
I don't say that.
I just,
I just give examples from history about the way good leaders behave and the way
badly misbehave and let people make their own decisions.
But somebody was hitting me up,
hey,
you know,
you need to,
you need to speak out.
And you know,
I said,
okay,
well here's my speech.
America is stronger than one man.
America is stronger than any one individual politician.
We're,
we're a massive,
you know,
massive ship and a massive ship takes a long time to turn.
And the checks and balances that are in place inside the government,
which are sometimes really,
really bureaucratic and,
and disappointing an aggravating because it's so hard to change things.
They're,
they're hard to change for a reason.
So am I worried that this is at this tipping point won't come?
No.
It'll come eventually because eventually free people,
the free people of America won't allow for things to go so far in one direction
or so far in the other direction.
We won't allow it now.
What makes it hard to reach that tipping point is because America,
it's so,
it's so beautiful in America,
right?
There's,
there's,
it's such a stress free life,
right?
It's just,
there's,
you know,
we were in the middle of two wars and that didn't affect the average American in
any way whatsoever,
that not even the oil prices,
like nothing affected them.
They were still driving the SUV to Starbucks and ordering a Latte with zero
impact.
And that was when we were fighting two wars and lead losing people every day.
On those battlefields.
It was no factor.
So what happens in Americas,
we,
we're,
we pretty much don't care as long as we're comfortable,
but if things start to get uncomfortable,
that's when I think the,
the real tipping point will come and there'll be a backlash one way or the
other.
Yeah.
All right.
I want to shift off some of the worst stuff,
but very quickly.
So since you mentioned the two wars,
the one that nobody ever talks about or even thinks about is Afghanistan,
which I think now it's the longest war we've ever been in,
right?
I mean,
this is the longest war.
It's still ongoing now.
It seems to me that nobody knows really why we're there or why this is so a and
going,
what the hell should we be doing or thinking about or will you need to,
it's never discussed,
period.
Yeah.
And it's interesting because this is something when,
when Trump,
if you remember Trump said,
hey,
what's the plan?
And he got a bunch of pushback and people were saying,
Oh,
who's he to asking?
And I was like,
well,
he's the president.
And so yeah,
you need some kind of a plan.
You need some kind of a goal and I do think that needs clear definition in
Afghanistan of what it is we're trying to make happen.
What does that look like?
I,
you know,
from my perspective,
when you get into these countries where you're trying to build something,
we're trying to,
you're not trying to build yourself and trying to allow them to be free.
That's what you're really trying to make happen.
You're trying to allow these countries to be free.
They're not going to be the same as us.
That's one thing that I'm fairly confident about.
There's different cultures that are going to adopt freedom and democracy in a
different way and you can't impose what we think it should be like on other
cultures because it doesn't match up perfectly,
but it can match up pretty well and individual human beings in these countries,
you know what they want.
They want a job,
they want to build a little business.
They want to be able to feed their kids.
They want their kids to have a better opportunity than they do.
That's what you can,
when you can provide some of that,
that will start to take hold and when you provide some of it,
other people in that country will look at it goes,
hmm,
that seems to be a pretty good deal over there.
I would like to try that too.
And pretty soon you can get freedom and democracy,
the attitude of it too to expand and so it takes a long time.
You know the average counter insurgency is seven years,
but they can take really,
really long time.
But
in my opinion,
and really through the history of the world,
eventually in my mind,
eventually at through history,
eventually the free individual will rise to the top and and rule and,
and they will rule themselves.
And so you have to give that opportunity for individual freedom.
You,
they have to have the opportunity to grow and to take root and take good solid
root and to grow and be strong enough that when tyranny comes along,
it can't just wipe it out because tierny can wipe out the individuals without
priming.
We've seen that big history to Tierny can wipe out and destroy individual
freedoms and individual really individual aspirations.
They can just be mopped up and destroyed by a tyranny.
Tyranny.
So you have to give freedom and individual freedom,
not just the time to sprout up a little bit.
You got to give it the time to take root because once people have tasted true
freedom and true opportunity,
they don't give it up.
And that's what I think you have to do.
You have to stay somewhere long enough that people understand what true freedom
is.
They recognize that it's theirs to protect and it has to be rooted strong enough
that it can't be white washed away by tyranny.
So then going all the way back.
So what are we doing in Afghanistan?
I mean,
do you sense that that's actually happening there?
Cause it's like something like 14 years or something and it's one of these
things where we oscillate too much on what it is that we're trying to accomplish
and what we're willing to sacrifice to accomplish it.
Because you know,
from an isolationist perspective,
from a,
okay,
let's just take of America,
take care of America.
Oh,
let's take the Taliban.
you want to live in like a world you want your country to be,
you know,
back in the stone age and that's how you want to live.
Okay,
cool.
We'll be over here doing our thing.
Like that's,
that's,
yeah,
that's uh,
all legitimate plant.
Hey,
you guys want to live in the stone age?
Cool.
We'll be over here with i-phones.
That's fine.
We don't care.
But then it's like,
okay,
but we're going to breed terrorists,
but okay,
we'll,
we'll comment on occasionally and knock those guys out.
How's that?
Okay.
We could do that.
And that's if that's the plan.
Okay,
let that be the plan.
But if we're going to stay there,
if we're going to try and get freedom to take root,
which I believe is the best thing to do because I do believe that we do have
some level of moral obligation to try and support individual freedom throughout
the world.
That's,
that's to me,
that's pretty self evident.
Does that mean that we have to jump in everywhere,
that there's oppression?
No,
it doesn't.
And we can't.
And it also means that inside those countries,
the human beings inside those countries also has a moral obligation to rise up
and fight on their own.
And I was nice about going back to Iraq was,
you know,
I've got friends that fought in Mozel as I took Mozal back,
but those were Iraqi troops that were moving from building to building,
taking massive casualties.
As a matter of fact,
one of my friends that was there said there was in the beginning of the Moselle
campaign,
the Americans were looking at each other saying,
hey,
these guys are taking so many casualties,
we're going to run out of Iraqi soldiers.
Like they're all going to die.
And the Iraqi soldiers continued to go forward and they continue to fight and
they ended up,
you know,
getting the upper hand.
And so when they say that,
that we were greeted as liberators is,
it actually is
true.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Oh my God.
I mean in Mozel.
Oh,
it was I,
and again,
I wasn't there and I never fought in Afghanistan either.
But the guys coming back from Bozel,
those are the people were absolutely just they were,
they were,
they were being everything enslaved,
beheaded,
tortured,
everything.
It was absolutely,
it was heinous.
Yeah,
it was.
It was,
it was a heinous war.
Crime across the board.
So yeah,
absolutely.
So we are,
we've done a lot sort of out of our borders here,
but it's interesting you mentioned that,
you know,
in the middle we can be in the middle of all of these words and yet we can still
get a latte and we can still pay no attention to it and live our good lies.
Do you think there's a risk to our freedom here because of that?
That we've got it so freaking good that we almost don't know what freedom is
anymore?
Do I think it's an actual risk?
No,
no,
I don't.
I think that the minute things,
the minute you start really talking about taking away the personal freedoms of
Americans,
there will be real problems.
So,
okay.
Is that a risk?
Sure.
That that could be a risk.
I see that as a real small chance that things get bad enough where,
where mass groups of Americans say,
Oh yeah,
we're not,
we're not doing that.
You just crossed the line,
you know,
the,
the American revolution,
right?
Oh,
do you want to raise t taxes?
No,
actually we're going to fight a war against you.
You're not raising the tea taxes.
Right.
That's,
could it get to that point here?
Sure.
But you've got to remember what's going to be sacrificed and yeah,
that's one of the coolest things about the American revolution is the people
that fought it with the people that actually had the most to lose the people
that stood up.
So it would take,
it would take a lot,
but,
um,
I,
I don't,
okay.
I think it would take a lot to get there.
And if it gets there,
that'd be sad.
It'll be a sad day.
But I believe that freedom would prevail.
All right,
let's,
let's shift all together to sort of what you're doing now.
So podcasting,
writing,
all that stuff happened,
these kinds of conversations.
Um,
it's kind of cool that,
that people are paying attention to this stuff now,
isn't it?
When you started doing the podcast,
was that just sort of,
you were just going to throw it out there and see what happens and see if,
oh wow.
People might want to listen to long forum conversation.
Yeah.
I did a podcast with Tim Ferriss
and when he press stop on the recorder,
he said,
you should do your own podcast.
And then Joe Rogan heard it invited me on.
So it was on Joe Rogan's podcast in the middle of that podcast are rung and
said,
you should have your own podcast.
So when Tim Ferriss and Joe Rogan tell you to have a podcast,
they have a podcast.
You listen.
So I did.
And for me it's a,
it's a,
it's a great medium.
I always,
when I grew up,
I grew up listening to radio shows and so
I always liked listening to radio and that's essentially what it is,
is radio without commercials.
And
I get to talk about things that I'm interested in.
And again,
you know,
the,
some of the advice that I got when I started off was like,
oh,
you need to have guests all the time.
People are getting tired of,
you don't,
don't talk about these dark,
you know,
don't talk about these dark violent things on,
you can't talk about war all the time and you need to keep them shorter and all
this night and listen to anybody.
And My podcasts are really long.
Some of them are extremely heavy and dark and talk about some of the worst.
In fact,
I think we've covered most of the really the worst things that have unfolded on
the planet.
And they're long.
And I don't have a lot of guests,
you know,
I do have gas,
but I don't have a lot of guests.
So
the interesting thing is yes,
shockingly enough people,
people listen to it and the connection and the feedback is,
is awesome.
Yeah.
How do you think it's changed you
by going into all those dark places and talking about all this stuff and,
and expressing your ideas and all that?
Well I've gotten,
I've,
I've gotten a lot,
I've gotten a lot of experience out of it.
The experience I get out of it as I,
so I do a lot of book,
I covered a lot of historical books.
Like I said,
first person accounts of war and atrocity in that.
When I first started the podcast I say,
well you know I probably got,
I'll probably do five cause I got like five books that really had an impact on
me.
So I'll cover those books and then oh whatever.
That'll probably be it.
And then I said,
you know,
there was one more book that I really want to throw in this pot.
And then there was another one and it didn't take but you know,
five or six more podcasts where I said I'm never going to be able to do the pod
enough podcast to cover the things that I want to talk about.
And that's the way it's been.
So I've read,
I read basically a book a week for the last three years and you know,
I,
I finished doing all the books that I,
that I actually had already read.
And like I'm in like,
I dunno.
So you're like,
I better write some then.
Yeah.
Well I'd already written my first book when the podcast came out.
Uh Huh.
So,
so how has it changed me and the other,
the other great thing is I get to interact with all these people and
people come up and I know they do this to you.
Two people come up to me and they say,
I know,
I feel like,
I know it's weird,
but I feel like you know me.
And I'm like,
yeah,
you do know me.
Because how I am on the podcast is actually how I am.
That's just me.
And,
and then I tell them that I actually know them too.
Because if they've listened to me for 500 hours,
you haven't spent 500 hours listening to your water.
You know what I mean?
It's like that's just not happening.
Yeah.
So I do know them and then they gave great feedback and I learned a lot from,
from the books that I read,
from the people that I have had on and from the feedback that I get.
And Hey,
read this book,
look at this aspect.
So it's made me,
it's made me learn a lot.
So from first person war books and all your life experience,
how do we end up with,
we got two of them here,
I think.
Children's books.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Right here.
Well,
so there's the Dragon,
the Dragon.
So yeah.
Yeah.
I didn't,
I didn't write,
I didn't give Jordan any credit for it.
You know,
it's called Mike and the dragons Jordan.
Sorry.
Yeah.
Um,
I got four kids and as I started
continuing to hear back from people that were listening to what I was saying,
and the,
what I hear a lot is,
I wish I had this when I was a kid.
And of course my answer would be like,
I do too.
I wish I had the lessons from extreme ownership when I was a kid.
I wish I had the lessons from the discipline equals freedom field manual.
And I was a kid.
Absolutely.
And grown up or watching my own children grow up.
I just knew that the things that I tried to impart on them,
I figured I could put into stories where I could impart those values onto little
kits and make their lives easier and better.
And that's it.
So I started writing them and it was
surprising that at the,
the response,
the response has been,
you know,
people love him.
And you know,
one of my favorite letters I've gotten is I got this letter from this guy who,
you know,
he's saying I'm 37 years old and I was drinking and I was overweight and I was
doing it,
hadn't been promoted.
And I got all these problems going on his life.
And he said,
I read your book.
And I said,
okay,
I'm gonna wake up a little early.
Okay,
I'm gonna start working out.
I'm going to stop complaining.
Okay.
And he went through his whole letter and how now he had lost 52 pounds and he
had been promoted and he had stopped drinking and all this stuff.
And then the last line said,
the book I read was the way of the warrior kid,
which is aimed at kids.
But the lessons in there are completely universal and apply to your whole life.
So it's been,
it's been great.
And I get a lot of social media posts of little kids studying flashcards because
the premise of the warrior kid story is that there's a little kid who's,
he can't do any pull ups,
he doesn't know how to swim.
He's getting picked on by the school bully Kenny Williamson and he doesn't know
his times tables and the last day of school ends and he's all sad.
And then you remembers that his uncle Jake is coming to stay with him for the
summer and his uncle Jake was in the seal teams.
So his uncle Jay comes to stay and first day said,
hey,
you know,
what do you want to do tomorrow and do something?
You want to go for a swim?
And the kid goes a little notice swim and I don't know how to,
you know,
don't know my times tables getting picked on.
So the uncle says,
look,
these aren't problems we can solve all these,
gets them into Jujitsu classes,
teach them how to swim,
teaches them how to study using flashcards and other memorization techniques and
teaching them how to eat right,
teaches them to work out and the kid turns,
turns around.
And so that's that one.
Mike and the dragons is about facing your dragons and little kid that's scared
of everything and he finds a book under his bed and it's the opens it up quickly
and there's a bunch of pictures in it that looks scary of dragons and fire.
And so he's doesn't want to read it.
But there's also a picture in there of a little kid that looks confident and
like he knows what he's doing.
So he says,
all right,
you know what?
I'm going to read this book.
And then you turn the page in this book and you are now looking at the cover of
this next book,
which is called the dragon prince.
And that's the story of a kingdom where the king had died and now there was no
one to defend the kingdom from the dragons except for this little seven year old
prints.
And so he's scared.
He goes to get his father's sword in his father sealed to opens up this big war
chest.
And in there he pulls out the store against too heavy for him.
He pulls out the shield,
it's too heavy for him,
and he's even more scared now.
And then he sees a note at the bottom of the war chest and he pulls it out and
it's a note from his father,
the king who explains to him what he needs to do to stand up and face the
dragons and the story continues on.
So I enjoy storytelling.
Yeah.
Well I sent,
I sent an animated movie and I guess the last thing I got for you is what do you
do to relax after all this,
after all the work and everything else,
and it's a pretty intense life that you're living,
I'm guessing you're going to say working out,
but give me something off.
Well,
work.
Does that include Jujitsu?
Yeah.
Well,
that's still within the working out thing,
but whatever works for me,
that's it.
You know what?
I surf,
I do Jujitsu.
I hang out with my kids,
play guitar,
and
yeah,
I find this stuff relaxing.
It's enjoyable for me to to write.
It's enjoyable for me to talk to people about leadership and go out with my
company.
I saw up front and teach and align executives on leadership and watch them be
able to turn their company around or bring their company to the next level based
on 100% on leadership,
which is what I tell them.
I say,
look,
you've got this problem.
You've got that problem.
You've got another problem.
Every problem that you have inside your organization is a leadership problem.
I guess that means you slayed the dragon and you're,
you're doing the right thing in life.
It's been a pleasure,
man.
Appreciate you finally were able to do this and for more on Jacko,
you can follow him on Twitter at Jocko Willink.